okay we've told you about healthy food
with Candace but now we're talking Super
Bowl food all week long we've been
giving you recipes you can make at home
this one is so simple Chef Mario
Nellie's Southern Kitchen inside MGM
Grand gave us a spin on elote elote
fries
back with Chef Mario inside Nellie's
Southern Kitchen we are talking Super
Bowl Super Bowl Sunday It's gotta be
good and kind of Hardy yes and kind of
kind of not really that good for you
that's Super Bowl food that's the best
Super Bowl you got a vegetable for me
today just corn okay that's healthy it's
very healthy easy and this is roasted
and I just roasted this corn with butter
and taco seasonings really yeah just to
make it like I wanted to be a little
sweet and a little Spanish flavor flare
because we're gonna do some elote fries
even better okay so you got the corn now
the easy thing would be to go buy I want
the canned or the Frozen I would buy the
canned corn your favorite and just boil
it just a little bit okay and then add
drain it add all of your spices to it
and just put it to the side got it okay
get your favorite fry whatever fries
that you love I'm just going to add a
little salt and pepper
I'm just gonna squeeze a little lime
juice on those fries and these are nice
big thick ones so they're going to kind
of soak up some more yeah she wanted to
soak up this flavor I'm just gonna layer
these fries a little bit so I'm going a
little bit of fries
a little bit of this wilted corn now
this mixture here is just Mayo a little
bit of sour cream okay to like kind of
finish just to kind of thin it out lemon
juice lime juice
and then that's it salt and pepper okay
okay my family loves extra sauce and
extra cilantro
it's amazing different should it be a
win for your Super Bowl
it is an absolute win it was so good so
some simple recipe instructions on our
website 8newsnow.com share him getting
hungry I'm ready yeah what am I seeing
there little glass of Hennessy next to
them maybe or maybe a little okay all
right Heather